No. I locked out.
Pepper: Honey.
Tony: Slow down. Slow down. And I'll, I'll spell it out for you.
Pepper: You're totally rambling.
Tony: No, I'm not. no, you told no, I'm not lost me look, you know, how
You're having a dream dream. You got a pea. Yeah
Okay, and then you're like, oh my god, there's no bathrooms. What I'm gonna do Oh Saints watching
Oh, wait and in real life, you actually have to pee. Yes. Yeah. Okay, everybody has that right? That's the point
I'm trying to make I proposed that last night I dreamt I get a kid
so real
We named him after your eccentric. Uncle Oh, what was his name Morgan Morgan. So you woke up in naturally we were
Expecting. Yes now, please
maybe
We don't even have a wedding date yet. You set argost 27th. That's the decoy date
Because this media circus that's going on is driving me crazy. Okay. This is me on edge
I'm sorry, because I'm trying to keep all the pictures out of the paper and off the internet
So your weddings not ruined no one's working harder than remember that kid from TMZ that you had me trade paint with on the FDR
Drive well, I got a case against me now. That's my fault. Yeah, it's your fault. Lou doesn't a plus
I'm half like the godfathers really funny. Now, you gotta go to court. That's why when you get out of the car and just distress
Burt I see you Burt
Burt you son of a bitch tell me a break come here man. We gotta get him a girlfriend, you know, anyone anyone
Everybody, it's Charlie
We got a whole bunch of infinity war to talk about probably one of the most
important scenes in the entire movie
Because of how it charts the timeline it gives you a beginning a middle and an end point for Iron Man's character
So we got to break it down. If you're brand new to the channel. Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
There's a new brand of that infinity war blu-ray giveaway - all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
And leave a comment on the video
the important thing about this is that it foreshadows what the end of Iron Man's arc is going to be because I think everybody is
Really sad that things are ending
It's gonna be this bookend for all these phase 1 Avengers, even though some will continue into phase 4, not everybody is gonna die
But in contrast to the really downer
Infinity war ending leaving all the heroes broken we could talk all day about that
It sounds like Avengers for the tone is gonna be wildly different and I think it will have a much more
Hope ending that will get you really excited about what's going to be happening next
Like there will be a couple people that definitely stay dead and it'll be a huge bummer
but for the most part
Things will end in a very positive way Josh Brolin has been going on and on about how he's been thinking about these two
Avengers films as this grand Shakespeare play most of Shakespeare's comedies end in weddings
Which is why I think it's so important that this scene happens at the beginning and obviously a lot of these films have been framed
around Iron Man's character
he's been the base of the pyramid the backbone that they've built the last 10 years of Marvel on so his arc is one of
The more important ones for foreshadowing how things are going to end
So what do they say during this that they did not say during the scene that made it into the movie, Tony
Mistakenly thinks that they've scheduled their wedding for August 22nd after the movie has aired in theaters
It gets a little bit meta too because it's sort of like them ending in a real world way, too
Like after next summer the Avengers will be moving into the new phase of their lives and the old phase one Avengers will be going
Out to pasture but within the world of the movie it was gonna be happening a couple months after they have this conversation
So think of everything during infinity war is the prime timeline everything is left at the end. Everyone's lost
They're broken, but Doctor Strange has this big plan
We all know they're gonna try and fix everything during Avengers 4 possibly resetting things and creating a new timeline
Just remember that we'll come back to that. So Pepper is saying that no
No
That's the decoy date to mislead the paparazzi
Also a bit of a meta term for the fans like trying to figure out the plot of Avengers 4
No
We're throwing out decoy information to throw people off Tony responds by saying they need to get married before that peppers like no
We need to get married after that date and then happy is like just elope just go do it go do it right now
Remember in the actual version of the scene that we saw in theaters
She says you should have shirts in your closet. Not suits of armor
So he's metaphorically hanging up his arc reactor
Thinking about having a child with her becoming more
Domestic passing off the day-to-day of saving the world to the new guys
Like spider-man and Black Panther so you think about this?
They're very openly foreshadowing how they're going to end the movie
Probably on the wedding of Tony in Pepper
like in the way that they
Foreshadow those people coming back and the way the soulstone works how it preserves life after death because they turn all these people to ash
But Black Panther and spider-man among are definitely getting sequels spider-man gonna be happening right after Avengers for next year
So they're very open about the way they foreshadow plot twists
Which is what they're doing in this conversation here is their foreshadowing the end of Iron Man's arc specifically
But because his arc is so important to the entirety of all this it also serves as the big celebratory
event in the reason for them all to be on-screen together like Sebastian Stan says that he had a scene with
Every Marvel character ever on screen at the same time. You would do that at a wedding
So, you know people expecting a doubt or ending like what if they're at a funeral like Captain America's funeral
That would be another reason for all the characters to be on-screen together
But remember infinity war was the downer ending
Avengers 4 will probably be a much more hopeful ending but here's the thing in the prime timeline
Remember, we're still at the end of infinity war right now
the Russos revealed that Iron Man was permanently damaged emotionally by spider-man's death and
physically from his battle with Thanos and
unable to
Move forward given the fact that his whole thing is that he's the Futurist who builds himself new armor upgrades on the fly every year
And in Avengers 4 in this promo art, he's wearing the exact same suit of armor
And this looks like is happening towards the end of the film because Captain Marvel's teamed up with them like this is their final battle
With Thanos is implied that there's a big time jump
So if he's wearing the same suit of armor
That means that he's probably stuck in a rut meaning that when he came back to Planet Earth
It was a little bit like after the first Avengers film remember how crazy he went
They didn't deal with it till Iron Man 3. So safe to say that after he came back
He and pepper probably never went through with the wedding things move forward, but the whole idea things are more hopeful in Avengers
They learn to be true heroes. They fixed the universe and reality. There's also some implied a
Time-travel because using spider-man as a benchmark spider-man's movies moved one year at a time
We know Scott Lang is going to be time traveling a little bit because of the time vortices inside the quantum realm
Implying that there's at least a couple years between the end of infinity war in the beginning of Avengers 4
So they fix everything by the end of Avengers 4
it implies that they're creating an alternate timeline or an alternate reality where things turn out really awesome for them because they made all the
Right moves and they fixed everything so beginning to end
Infinity war in a vengers for only actually take place over the course of a couple weeks
even though like all the Avengers that fix everything will probably
Remember everything that happened like Iron Man will probably remember all the things that happened after he saw spider-man die
Spider-man will remember dying Doctor Strange will remember everything they'll have lived several years
Even though as we view it from beginning to end in Avengers for only a couple of weeks
We'll have gone by they can have their wedding that will satisfy
Iron Man's request to move the wedding up great
We need to do it now. We need to do it quickly and it will also satisfy peppers comment
We needed to do it after the date because even though she might not recognize that all that time has passed Iron Man
We'll know it'll would have been several years inside his head
so everything is just pointing towards them being relatively honest when they're
Foreshadowing this potential wedding because remember how they set that up during spider-man homecoming
What am I going to tell you something how about
How you still got that ring to it I think eight are you kidding I mean carrying this since 2008
Like I just thought that it was meant to be this funny joke
But no no, no turns out they mean to pay that off
It goes all the way back to the Iron Man films
Like he was getting ready to propose got a little sidetracked with all the stuff
He was doing with the Avengers, but finally he's paying that off
It just feels like the Russos mean to pay off this wedding and that would be like the big
Event to end it on but let me know in the comments
How do you think they'd end Avengers 4 that makes you happy about what happened? And
Excited for what's coming up next?
What will happen is is there's a whole bunch of other stuff to get through the Deadpool blu-ray is dropping really soon, too
So I'm sure there'll be some bonus features for that
I'll do videos whenever it does leave all your requests in the comments below where you wait for everything
Click here to re-watch that venom trailer a billion more times and click here for that other infinity ward's deleted scene
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight